Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Hey guys!
Welcome!
We have a little pivot today today.
We're drinking!
Wait, I don't hear Matara.
Why don't I hear?
Is she mute herself?
I think she- I can't mute herself!
Wait, I went one, but we swapped!
I was just like, worry!
Oh, just opening my first can of hard ice tea right now.
Oh, yeah, would you mute yourself like accidentally?
No, I purposely was like just opening my mouth.
Oh, they're like, Matara's muted.
She's muted.
She's just fucking with you guys.
Just rage baiting.
I'm sorry.
That's what I do.
I think the older I get, the more I realize that like being
an annoying brat is my life's calling, you know, I just love
it.
Do you found your purpose?
I have.
It's to be annoying.
Thank you for inviting me over.
No, of course.
I've been drinking a long time, but this is for you, Matara.
I feel like you needed it.
My alcoholism is seeping through to you.
Thank you.
Yeah, I feel like, you know, what a great time to be an
alcoholic, you know?
Might as well start today.
Is this all in your apartment?
This is so nice.
Yeah.
I got you a red wine.
I knew you.
I knew you like that shit.
Yeah, look, I knew you got that like that.
Oh, this is so fancy.
Yeah, you can tell I didn't take down my Christmas
decorations because I don't keep it's been out for 20 years.
Okay, I need your I need your honest take on this.
Does that bother you if people don't take off their
Christmas decos?
No, I don't care.
I was like, you do Christmas every day, you know, like let's
have some Christmas cheer.
My birthday falls around February and to me, I'm like, no,
you cannot take these out until like at least after my
birthday.
I could I would have a Christmas tree all year round.
Yeah, you know what?
Merry Christmas.
Also, you stopped moving.
Yeah, I'm moving to my end.
I don't know why not.
I think you're...
Maybe there's too much on us.
On the both of us, maybe.
Oh, because now, hold on.
You're moving on my end.
Let me check.
Why?
I wonder.
Hold on.
Hmm.
Is it me?
I've noticed.
I wonder if it's like also my internet's been kind of weird.
Wait, let's go east coast.
I think yeah.
No, no, no.
I'm on the west coast.
Oh, I think you're forgetting.
You're like...
bounce between time zones how do you do it i don't how big
it can stop it's like i don't know like you travel so much
too i don't know how you do it i mean hey you you've been
kind of obviously no spoilers but you've been kind of
traveling a little bit as well how's everything with you how
you holding up with that i want to be i just want to stay at
home i just i don't know i'm just tired of traveling also
sound i don't know if i'm soundguessing live but how is
matara right now is she loud enough we don't have brain
cells you guys hear me also one reason why we're not we
pivot is that we don't have brain cells right now to play
video games right now i um i didn't even tell my audience
yet but i will do like small disclaimer this is a little sad
everybody just small disclaimer um a friend of a really
close friend um took their life and i and i found out about
it and and you know it's one of those things where even
though i've met this person the last time i think like 12
years ago but it was still kind of a casual friend in a
bigger friend group and i yeah i think that makes with like
everything else i was doing i'm like doki listen i just i
worry if we like play a game or anything like putting on you
know that kind of extra and then she had the brilliant idea
of like hey let's yeah let's just drink our problems away
you know let's hide it
Yeah, it's just one of those things where like, you know, I
think sometimes things happen and I feel as you get older
too and like, it's like if somebody you know gets into a car
crash or something, it takes you a second and you're like,
oh my God, life is short and precious.
Yeah, that's why like I figured, you know, we can just have
a little talk here just to distract ourselves and, you know,
hang out and, you know, appreciate life, you know, life is
short.
So I'll just hang out and have fun.
You're drinking.
So to me, I'm like, damn, I am.
Yeah, just for you, Matara.
That's for you.
When you like stop streaming, oversleep streams, become an
alcoholic, all that, deadbeat, like that's going to be
because of me.
I'm so excited.
Wait, why is deadbeat?
Wait, what's going on with are you?
Where's the deadbeat coming from?
I'm just, I don't know.
Maybe what if you become like a deadbeat like edible parent
because you're just drinking so much, you know?
I hope not.
I hope this will lead to actual alcoholism.
You're going to see me at eight.
soon I'm gonna meet you there I'm gonna meet you there next
year but I'll be like oh shit you're here too they're like
how about pointing me yeah I'll be like hello my name is
Doki and like hello Doki and I'm an alcoholic because of
this bitch right there across from me wait well you'll be
sharing a story about a past job I'd be like wait a second
wait a second do I know her what are you drinking I'm
drinking hard iced tea I don't I can't do wine I'm not a fan
of wine I'm sorry Matara I mean I feel like you know when it
comes sometimes to these things you're like oh I'm sorry I
don't like this thing I'm like I hey no sweat off my back I
don't know like for me I just like I that's why it's also
why I don't drink a lot it's because like I just don't like
the taste of alcohol that's why I always drink like I drink
like alcohol that hides the taste of alcohol so that's why I
love like flavored soju and like cocktails and shit and my
favorite is um what's it called the the orange juice one a
screwdriver or no the screwdriver because like if you i
don't know if you ever had a screwdriver but it hits the
taste of alcohol so well and it was like but you had a
mimosa where it's kind of like sparkling wine and yeah
orange juice but i just hate sparkling anything i just i'm
just a fizzy person that's fair are you into like um bubble
i mean not me asking you for boba are you gonna into bubbles
have you ever heard of dumplings it's this like i mean you
mean it's great for food the food no but like are you into
like sweet drinks like bo since you're not into fizzy are
you into like boba or other yeah yeah i'm just into sweet
drinks in general and well not obviously not too sweet but
like uh i just i just i don't know i just i feel like
alcohol there's just that the aftertaste just doesn't yeah
don't fuck with it see i am kind of your opposite where i
love that like alcohol kind of like has a strong taste and
like drinking it it kind of feels like i got a little
punched in the throat and i'm like i feel the same way about
spicy food i feel the same way like i like bitter foods i'm
i think that's just you getting older myself but i'm always
like i've honestly even as as a young woman i know i am a
hag but even as a young woman i had the like taste palette
of an old man like i love like a little baby is like i never
be really yeah yeah i always like like literally people call
it like old man foods like i love stinky and like i also
love organ meats like durian like what do you mean by stinky
like foods that are that are smelly um like foods that other
people like durian yeah i haven't had i've only had durian
in an ice cream and i liked it like usan wouldn't let me
have the real durian because i was hung over and Look,
Matara, I just don't think you should be having a real
durian when you're hung over.
Wait, but why?
Where's the correlation between?
It's because, like, for example, children, they'll eat foods
that are like bland a little bit, you know?
Like they'll eat bland foods and stuff like that.
And then when you're usually typically from what I've seen,
like old men or women, they'll like like stinky tofu,
nottoe, organ meats, anything that's kind of like rich and
like, I don't know.
It just has like a taste that's a little bit more.
yeah am i crazy everybody or have you heard of this as well
so it's like yeah you can't eat durian when you're drunk i
think it's just like durian's just not a like not a thing
that you can see a lot so i didn't even know that it was
that was a thing i love natto for somebody asking like
pungent food i loved oily like natto yeah so um i've i've
all i've always had the palette of an old man which was many
many do you have any favorite foods what are your like my
favorite food um pasta um i fucking love jollybee i was it
was between jolly i was gonna order between jollybees or
sushi because i was craving the jollybee spaghetti have you
had jollybees yet yeah i i've had it in philippines as well
oh yeah i'm like um i'm like obsessed with the the spaghetti
from jollybee so i was tempted but i was like you know what
i really want sushi My favorite, my favorite, like, growing
up poor person food has been spaghetti and ketchup.
And then everybody talks shit about me, but Jollybee
spaghetti is kind of spaghetti and ketchup because it's
sweet.
Really?
Oh, I guess.
The ketchup sweetness.
Yeah.
I've never had spaghetti and ketchup.
Like, is it?
I think because I'm Asian.
And they're grew.
Isn't that just like a, that's like a spaghetti and ketchup.
That's like a, like a white person thing, right?
like rice and ketchup or something like that right like
maybe rice and soy sauce maybe maybe and soy yeah yeah like
i've never had spaghetti and ketchup before i think like
growing up i mostly just had chinese food or or okay or the
pokemon the the pokemon macaroni oh that shit was fire i
love that shit i missed that the little shapes you either
they brought it back um recently for And then it's getting
scalped so hard at the moment on eBay.
Did you ever have that oatmeal with that had like little
dinosaur eggs?
And then it would melt and you would have like a little
sugar candy that we're little dinosaurs.
No, I never had those.
I didn't grow up.
I didn't grow up with oatmeal.
I think I just didn't have oatmeal growing up.
I think mostly it's just for breakfast.
My mom just made me cereal with like Lucky Charms.
I think my favorite.
This is like my guilty pleasure.
Like, but it's like the ones where it's like, It's like the
rabbit one where the little pellets, right?
No, the blue, the, not blue, the black rabbit, the brown
rabbit.
Yeah, Nesquick, that rabbit.
Nesquick is amazing.
And then you pour it and then you stir it and it's chocolate
milk.
That was my favorite growing up.
You love Nesquick.
You have to try Reese's Pieces.
It's like, it's the same thing as Nesquick, but it's peanut
buttery.
I don't, yeah, but the thing is, I didn't grow up with
peanut butter too.
So, like, I think peanut butter, you don't love it.
It's like an acquired taste, I feel like.
I think like if you never grew up with peanut, I think I
realized like if you didn't grow up with peanut butter, it's
such a weird taste.
Cause like had peanut butter as an adult.
So I had tried it as an adult cause I didn't eat Reese's
pieces before either.
And it was just such a, I never had that taste before.
So I was just like, oh.
You know, this is funny.
Cause I feel like in a lot of, if you look at Chinese food
in Canada or America, they'll usually have peanut butter
sauce for like dumplings and stuff like that so my first
thought was oh peanut butter dumplings but no no like you
yeah that's what do you mean you never had general town's
chicken you know yeah that's called a canadianized
americanized food madara wow that's no pb and j no no no pb
and j i think first time i've had jam was when i was like in
middle school or high school because it was like those
buffet spreads and like you go to like have a buffet or
something and then they're like oh you want to have jam with
your bread and i was like jam with my bread where's my buddy
i guess that's like also a thing that um that you realize
like for example a lot of asian desserts will have like red
bean in them or they won't be as sweet or it's the opposite
but they'll be like so sweet they're using different
ingredients um i'm trying to think about what what i had as
an i mean i had a lot of things as an adult um um century
egg i love century egg in my congee oh my god the tiny eggs
right they're they're like the eggs that are so punchy oh
yeah yeah i remember they're like like they're like sort of
see-through right the see-through they're either black or
like see-through yeah yeah i hated those i'm sorry oh my god
it's like the flavor of egg times a thousand because they're
so yeah yeah i've tried it before i'm there i'm like for me
when it came came to eggs like i just didn't like picky with
my food like I always like take the yoke out and just eat
the whites that's it that's literally what I did all the
time okay so in Ukraine when I was a kid um you could so in
Canada we're not allowed to like eat the eggs raw because
apparently they're like not pasteurized in the same way or
something like that but in Ukraine yeah back in the 1900s
you could so I would see my grandma and her sister take
shots of vodka and I was like I shot two so they would eat a
raw egg gave a cup and then during nights what they would be
drinking i'd have like four raw eggs because they're like
what are we gonna do with this just give it to matara she's
our this is like our egg dumpster i would shoot like raw
eggs we can't waste our eggs guys but i always loved like
and that's one thing in japan i know that you can have your
eggs raw in japan yeah yeah because i love oh my god i
really love the taste of like that like raw yolk oh it's
like your guilty pleasure it really is takes shots of eggs i
mean i can't because in american and canada you can't yeah
yeah you had it's it has to be like europe or asia for it do
you have any guilty pleasure foods like that
it's not really a guilty pleasure like there's nothing wrong
with it but i fucking love foie gras i know it's so wrong
but why does it taste so good how do you like it do you like
it when it's like kind of boiled because it's like when they
like boil it like a sausage and you put it like a spread
then they have it when it's kind of like with jam tell me
everything okay i just love i honestly i love um i love like
everything about fagra like just to taste in general so like
it doesn't matter for me if it's spread or if it's just like
a just like a patty or anything i fucking love fagra so for
those who want to know i'm gonna like make myself look so
evil right now because they're like headphones in i'm just
gonna grab my wine so the reason why it's so bad is that the
way to get fagra is really really bad but it's so good it's
i know it's like i can't help it like if there's ever an
opportunity to get fagra i will order it because i'm just
like it's so good and i blame my mom um i will shift the
blame to my mom it was nurture versus nature and i was
nurtured into fagra because my mom was obsessed with fagra
you were raising a fagra family you know raised with enough
it wasn't my fault it was not my fault i was raised in a
fogra household because my mom loved fogra and then she
would make me eat fogra and then i was like oh it's so good
too so she introduced me to it so so it's not my fault and
sweet and it's rich yeah i was a victim i was a victim also
sound guy i raised up matara a little bit more so let me
know if it's a lot better guys um but anyway So the reason
why Fagra is really, really bad is because to get Fagra,
they sort of force feed the ducks to get it.
So they get, they mix them, they make, basically it's the
liver, it's a duck liver.
And, and the way to get a really good Fagra, it has to be a
really big liver.
So, so basically they get like a little funnel and then they
start feeding the duck.
And then when the liver is nice and fat, you, you take the
ducks.
liver and then into my stomach it goes up and again like i
do want to be mindful that like it's not much different if
you're eating you know chicken or beef or stuff like your
chickens are also getting that kind of like you know
fattening and so do the beefs and so do stuff like that so
sometimes people be like oh how could you eat this okay but
you're also eating all this other stuff so in the we're all
in the wrong guys we're all bad people actually it's the
french it's the fault of the french yeah it's the french
it's the french how dare you invent braggra how dare you
look what you did now look at that i was a victim i i was a
victim of the french it's the french same thing for me like
i started working at a french restaurant i had to try that i
had to learn how it's done i salad no no like yeah it was it
was the french's fault yeah how dare they come up with such
an amazing dish how exactly it's it's absolutely like their
fault you know yeah um no never i felt incredible um when
you said pasta do you have like because for me personally i
love pasta but i tend to like kind of like the the like
thicker pastas like i love a good udon or like a noki like
any pasta that's kind of like thicker slurpier if that makes
sense um i mean do you have a preference of like yeah i get
you i don't like when i eat like ramen stuff i always get
the thickest noodles i don't yeah i also have spaghetti too
or pasta in general i just don't like linguini or like angel
hair it's just too thin the really thin ones yeah the
texture just doesn't it just doesn't fuck with me i don't
fuck with the texture in general because it's just like too
much you know when you're taking a slurp of like an angel
hair It's just too many strands in your mouth.
Hey, I do love like the thick.
And I also love the flat noodles, like a good Thai noodle or
stuff like that.
That's like flat and thin.
Like as long as it, there's like, you know, as long as it's
a big noodle and not like you said, like the thin, thin,
thin.
Yeah, yeah.
For sure.
Oh my God, today.
Oh yeah, where you go?
What?
How do you feel about the bowtie pasta?
The bowtie pasta.
Bowtie pasta is nice.
I like all types of pasta except for like the thin ones.
That's really it.
when it's shaped like a bow tie when it's shaped like a bow
tie nice and funny okay go on today oh my god today i was i
was gonna tell this story uh to my chat but today um right
after doka meme i had a fire alarm today at like three three
in the morning yeah yeah because you're like am i okay and i
was like yeah i i basically woke up at 3 p.m uh today
because because like i said um there was a fire alarm and
then you know usually okay my chat was like you should stop
doing that but usually every time there's a fire alarm i
just stay at my i just stay in my apartment because like
like almost every time like every other every time has been
a false alarm so you're like oh surely i can't burn this
that's fine it'll stop it'll stop after a couple of minutes
because usually that's what happens but then you know it was
three in the morning and i was like that's weird because you
why would they do a fake fire alarm at three in the morning
so i actually went down this time for real the moment i
heard it because i was like because also like there's nobody
down in the lobby as well because i have like uh my
apartment has like top security and stuff but for some
reason at three or three in the morning there was no
security there so i was like that's that's weird yeah i was
like that's off but in the end like but in the end when i
was like waiting outside because obviously there was a giant
fire alarm so dad was like he doesn't he like the sound.
So I had to wait outside.
There was like... I'm not going to lie for the longest time.
I didn't know you were talking about your dog.
Oh, yeah, dad.
Yeah, I did.
Go on, sorry.
I called my dog dad.
there was just one fire truck.
And it's telling you there were two fire trucks.
And then three.
And then four.
And then five.
And I was just like, maybe this is real.
Like...
I was just like, oh my God.
You're like still burning everywhere?
I was just like, wow, I think this is a real fire.
And the six-five truck came on.
It stopped after six.
I was like, oh, no.
I was in the middle of doing autographs too, for the doka-me
stuff.
I was like, oh, no.
What about the autographs?
I won't be able to finish it in time.
I was like, I was just like thinking about that.
I know, I was like, what about my other stuff?
I was in my head.
I was like, oh, no.
I wasn't able to finish my autographs.
autographs like how long we'll have to be outside for if
they burn what if they all burn all your photographs no no
it was like a digital thing i was just literally just just
doing it was like digital checkies so i was literally doing
that while when the fire alarm came on i was like oh no i
have to stay up even long i was like in my head i was like i
have to stay up even longer to finish this i was like did
you end up finishing them all no problem i finished it at
like uh what was it i went to bed at six yeah i finished at
six in the morning because that was when i was we were
allowed back into the apartment but luckily luckily because
i live um i told my chat like they're like why don't you by
the way might be a little dangerous but i did use the
elevator
i did might be a little dangerous
to be fair she inhaled the fumes to be fair I was not the
only one I was not the only I was like to be fair to be fair
I was not the only one in the elevator I was not yet so they
know the reason why is that there's more than 30 floors in
my apartment and i live above i am one of those people that
are on the 30 plus floors lucky so that's awesome so but
yeah i was thinking like i was just thinking like maybe i
was thinking like maybe the fire if it was a fire maybe it's
not that bad so so i was like honestly i'll just use the
yellow the time it'll take you to go downstairs from the
30th floor like yeah you'd be yeah you know i get it yeah
and then we check no yeah i i helped there was like a little
rice in my throat um and then um basically when i came when
uh like people who are 30 and above um we uh we get to go
No, like the I know, I know it was You were like I know you
wouldn't relate to it I know like you're used to saying that
because You're a hag But
So basically So basically What happened was that Luckily our
elevators are divided Between floors So people who are below
Um the 25 floors and under have to use a separate elevator
so i get to like like people who are like in 25 under above
get to use the other other side of so there's a left and a
right side elevator and so we on the people who are above
get to be let in early because apparently the fire was at
the bottom floors so we were safe so so like it didn't
affect us.
So I was like, yeah, I get to go home early.
That's not how fires work, but, but like, I get it.
I get it.
Yeah, it's just, it's just because like, it didn't affect
the elevator on our side.
So we were allowed to go back.
So it affected one floor.
It affected, well, the firefighters said we could go back
up.
Okay.
They, they said we could go back up.
So if anything happens, we get to sue the firefighting
company.
We get to sue the firefighters.
And that's, since we get to sue the government if something
happens unfortunately it's like impossible in Canada in
Canada you know those stories of like if a car drives over
you you can sue for a lot of money that does that's not in
Canada that's like really yeah USA stuff yeah yeah
unfortunately okay so so firefighters basically played with
our lives I mean yeah and they wouldn't mind they wouldn't
get yeah yeah they won't get in trouble like in the states
even your coffee cup it has to be like be careful your
coffee cup is hot and if you get burned you can sue not in
Canada how do you know that did you try actually why are you
so well versed in Canadian law about whether or not you can
sue the government number one uh immigrated to Canada in the
1900s yeah makes it easy number one number two worked in
service industry ah so like you were like briefed on stuff
like that yeah I know Matara is frozen it like happens ever
so I don't know what honestly I wonder if it's like
something so even though my roommate and I we live in like a
nice new apartment building we notice that like throughout
the apartment like even though we're both hardwired in I
think they're like throttling our internet plus um even like
I have to plug half my PC into the bathroom because like the
breaker will will break in my room and I'm like okay but
it's a modern building like it's a modern building I get
that my computer is like big what's going on that's weird it
has been going on but do you have fiber or no no fiber but
we start a modern building let me restart the stuff yeah i
don't know why like it's been really weird um yeah because
like yeah if it keeps being too problematic i might just
like have my discord little pp up if it's if it's yeah as
she you're back now so it's fun yeah i'm i'm like resetting
stuff but it's really really strange and i've noticed that
like it's gotten worse so i wonder if they're like just kind
of slowly throttling us or something like that could be yeah
because like i have fiber and i haven't had any trouble of
it lately but also like um like it might yeah like the
building was built with fiber intended because i when i
first moved into this apartment i was like i would like to
upgrade to fiber like i was calling uh the company the
internet company and they're like we really have fiber i was
like what i was like let's go i was What do you mean?
You didn't even know when to do it.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
You didn't even know you just felt like the bonus.
Cause like I was so confused cause I was like, why can't I
like, why like, um, usually when you order fiber, you have
to have a technician come in to set everything up.
Uh-huh.
But then like, so when I ordered the fiber option, um, for
my apartment, they were like, they were like, there was no
option to send a technician and I was so confused.
And I kept calling.
And they're like, we're going to try and set this up for
you.
And then they're like, ma'am, do you know you already have
fiverr set up?
And I was like, I do.
And she's like, yeah, just plug it in.
And it's all there.
And then he's like, I do.
Why is Matara so much bigger than Doki?
She's bigger than everyone.
What do you mean?
I'm 181.
I'm like 511.
I'm big.
guys yeah i'm technically standing on a little stool right
now what is what is your height i'm five foot two which by
vtuber standards you're average like you're yeah that's true
that's giant you're towering over over mint see i took my
vitamins i drink a lot of milk growing up guys ladies ladies
i drank milk
yeah it's crazy to think that like at five foot two you are
towering over so many other vtubers yeah technically that's
average height if you think about it in asia that's average
height okay what do you mean which in what world like what
is that supposed to mean because like in ukraine i think
average woman height is like five six yeah but that's
ukraine is that giant women there?
No, I think the one word like it's actually giant is when
you get into like, I think Sweden and the Netherlands.
Yeah, it's the- Average height for a woman is like five foot
nine, five, 10.
That's where you're like, hey.
I like how you know what the average height of women are in
different countries.
Yeah, I compare myself to the average woman.
You're just like, am I average height?
Let me see, women in different countries.
Am I average?
Are these women?
You gotta establish your dominance.
Who's taller?
But I feel like, you know, when you get to places like
China, that kind of gets skewed because there's just so many
people that you will have really, really tall people as
well.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, yeah.
It's either like really, really tall or average height like
me.
Did you hear somebody be like, average height?
I'm average height.
Like, what, like, 153, 154?
Yeah, my dad is really, really tall, but I clearly inherited
his tallest by being 5'2".
you say really tall he's like six feet up okay okay yeah
because like because because for i wouldn't be surprised if
you had been like my dad's really tall he's like five foot
eight yeah he's like five foot five no my dad's like i don't
remember exactly i remember he's above six feet and i
clearly inherited that height by being five foot two you
know what you could have been four foot nine if it wasn't
for your dad's that's true that's true my mom's shorter than
me So, like, thank God.
I got the middle.
I inherited the middle part.
Damn, you're good for your dad.
Yeah, thank God.
He must really stand out when he's, like, walking around.
He does.
Like, you know how, like, when you're lost and you just look
for the tall guy, that's how I would find my dad.
I was just looking to see, and he'll just, like, poke above
everybody.
And I was like, there he is.
When I'm, like, lost, like, you know, like, when you're
shopping and stuff with your parents, they like you like
piece off of them and you're like where are they and like
there he is like you see him i want to i want to know since
we're kind of talking a little bit about like different
different topics um you so you've been traveling quite a bit
yeah yeah uh what is some stuff that you're excited to kind
of like you know get working on once you're once you're a
little bit more situated uh i want to i told you about this
before but i just want to do more like creative personal
creative projects leon i really miss doing i know you told
me but i want to make sure you tell them too yeah they they
know i told i said it several times about how like i really
do miss doing personal creative projects of course like
jaguars and miss like seeing stuff like that too and soon
everything will calm down i hope i don't know honestly
things are wild adulthood just like going saying like yeah
hey i just gotta get through this week i'm so sorry it
should be better but then it just yeah it was a project like
that it never ends yeah there was a project I was working on
and then um when I had to do the fantastic reality stuff I
had to put that and postpone and I felt so bad because um it
was I was supposed to be working on something on May and
then and then like everything paused in May so now it's like
literally me yeah that was literally me same thing and i
keep telling them almost i'm like guys please like i think
after june i should be fine but i say this but then like a
million other things and then i'm sure you know yeah because
few things keep coming in and then more things come in and
then you're like wait okay so because i did a concert now
i'm getting all these other opportunities yeah music every
month is a hell month to them yeah that's the same for me
like i didn't think i would chase a lot of music projects
too and i like so many music stuff lining up because of the
good the girlfriend cover uploaded because people were like
wait wait she can sing i was like i did it i tricked them
all i fooled them all you're thinking i can sing i mean look
let's let's let's let's be honest and say that we've
improved a lot i think practice unfortunately i hate to say
it but practicing and rehearsing does make a difference
right i did not practice that song i no but you've been
singing more which means like you kind of got better at it i
would sing it like randomly at karaoke and then during that
time i did the maid cafe with mint um it was just a random
thing like because we were like uh i forgot about that song
for a while and then during that maid cafe i did with mint
um she was saying how she's planning on singing new songs
for every session and because like at first i was just gonna
sing like oh these two songs and uh just these two and then
when she gave the idea it's like oh i'm going to do new
songs every session is like i should do that too so each
session is unique and then i was like and then like the
night before i was like looking through my plate like
karaoke playlist and stuff trying to figure out what to sing
i was like i should do girlfriend that's like a huge
throwback and then from there and then when people were like
oh my god so fun i was like i was like it was just i just
realized wait i could do a cover of this song yeah yeah
honestly that cover because i've been i love nickelback and
i love nickelback and that cover inspired me i'm like you
know what i will do a cover of nickel back i don't care y
'all you're getting some nickel back yeah i said look at
this photograph my my favorite song is actually called
saving me yeah um but i also love someday but i could do
photograph like you gotta do photograph that's the classic
okay girlfriend your favorite song is that way you covered
it girlfriend and skater boy i grew up with skater boy more
than girlfriend but I think girlfriend sound personally I
think girlfriend sounds better I think sometimes when it
comes to like passion covers you gotta do the stuff that
like gives you like for me even though someday is a less
popular song than photograph it gives me that like I get
into it you know like yeah I remember that meme that's me
that's me when I do cover songs I do cover that's why my
cover all over the place in terms like it's all like meme
songs uh yeah i mean you've always been a yeah i've been a
it's always shitpost i've just been shit doing shit post
covers uh because it's like it's fun it's it's like because
it's like you know everyone does like you know the classic
japanese songs or like you know like oh everyone does these
cover songs you hear them all the time but whoever heard who
does five nights at freddies like which v2 does five nights
at freddies I'm not VTV.
You are.
I saw your concert where you were like doing kind of like,
what was it, like just dance moves or whatever they are for
one of your...
Oh, I'm Han Solo.
I'm Solo.
I'm Han Solo.
Yeah.
It was awesome.
I've always wanted to do a cover of that because it's always
like, it's always stuck in my head every time.
And it's just so good.
Like, I've always wanted to do the dance moves from that
song too.
I mean, exactly.
You freaking did it.
um hold on i was gonna say something uh i lost my train of
thought cover cover but in russian we say that like if it's
important it'll come back before your wedding day so when i
was five so i'll never come back yeah i was like so what if
i get married tomorrow mom and she's like we're five shut
the fuck up you never know and then she's like wait she was
right she's doing this out of spite since she was five she's
like i'm gonna prove my mom wrong and never get married and
it's all decided at five years old all because of that yeah
yeah i i am contrarian like that in a homic cover music
cover vtuber singing oh you got this i believe it's hard i
have old i believe oh yeah we were talking about this
earlier how like we felt like the older we get and the more
we we stay as a streamer the dumber we get to oh my god i i
used to be so studious I used to like now now I'm like wait
somebody today I was talking to a friend of mine and they're
like oh I'm moving to Belfast and I'm like Belfast it's in
Dublin it's in Ireland oh my dumb ass I was like oh Belfast
oh like give me a minute hold on let me let me go into my
mind palace what oh the Sherlock mind palace how was I gonna
tell you it's gonna bother me
she's thinking she's thinking guys i have to be like help
her guys dragon's momos help her start spinning some random
stuff up maybe some a key word can trigger it cover song
avril levine i appreciate that you're doing meme songs like
you know what it's fine i if it comes back comes back i
gotta let it go i gotta let it go It's all right.
It's all right.
You'll remember it.
It'll be like in two hours.
You're going to be like, oh my, I remember that thing I
wanted to tell you.
The worst is I'm going to be taking a shower tonight and be
like, oh my God, that's the thing I wanted to tell Doki.
What the hell?
Yeah, I think with the projects and stuff, it's just, it
gets so like, you also don't want to say no to opportunities
because there's also this like feeling of like, wow, what if
I say no and then it never comes back?
how i regret it yeah that and then you think about your fans
you're like i'd love for them to experience this and have
this you know exactly uh like yeah that happened to me like
yesterday where um i was i was a little late to my member
stream because uh i just found out i had two tournaments on
the same day that got scheduled on the same day and i was
trying i was trying to see if i could make it work and do
back-to-back tournaments and then yeah because i i can't say
what other one you know you know they're already the
overwatch one that i wanted to yeah yeah so one was the
overwatch one the other one i can't say yet because they
have to announce it first before i can say it and but like
literally uh it was supposed to work like in my head i was
like i can make this work because one was in the morning and
the other one was like in the evening but then the other one
was planning on swapping that to the afternoon so i was just
like oh no so i had to Yep.
It's tough.
It's tough because like, I don't know.
And then you also think about, well, I also want to stream.
Like I, you know, you showed me vampire crawlers.
You.
Yeah.
But I know you, I didn't know I have love because I know you
love Rogue.
Like, and then I knew I wasted time playing and I want you
to waste time and not do your work too.
Yeah.
I'm gonna take you into an alcoholic.
See, it works out.
alcoholic and I'm making sure she doesn't do any work so
it's working out but I'm just hoping that I feel like when
you've been a streamer it's kind of hard sometimes because
when you've been a streamer for a long time like sometimes I
think the natural order of things is like sometimes you pull
back from streaming and you focus on some other stuff and
then you come back to streaming again but I definitely feel
a little guilty sometimes when I can't prioritize streaming
as much as I would love to yeah um I can't prioritize I
think that's everyone because yeah it's just hanging out no
i just saying i think that's like every streamer has uh like
has that similar feeling where you know you want to stream
more but like and it's hurt it's it's scary to take like
take like rest days and stuff because you're just like oh
what if you know what if everybody disappears afterwards you
know like it's always such an like underlying fear for us
too as the content creators also i just realized sound guy
was like please put
a little bit higher okay is it better now sound guy awesome
nobody's ever told me that i'm quiet before this is oh my
god oh my is she are you okay are you okay yeah this never
happens nobody's ever been like wow you're so quiet you're
so mindful virginal pure beautiful wow yeah i think it's
also because i'm also really loud this is great yeah yeah so
i lately my screams have been a little bit like voice
critical vibes i'm like wow uh but yeah i hope matara wasn't
too quiet earlier on so i hope you guys were able to hear
her yap because i'm you know this is a this is a team effort
drinking together hey everybody i can everybody hi honey i
can talk like this okay why are you giving me a spoken boy.
Hey, honey.
Can you play the fallout?
Hey, there, Spoochkin.
You're like a ghouls.
We were during member stream, we were trying to come up with
ideas for future member streams.
And one that was like, why don't you do like really bad
ASMR, like those shitpost ASMR?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
And they're like, hey, hey there, little boy.
Are you ready to have some fun?
Wait, I can do it close.
Hey, there, little boy.
You should do one where you're like, you're ready to have a
good time.
You're like dismembering your dragoons.
It's like, I'm like kidnapping you, stuffing you into a bag,
beating you up.
Like that.
Yeah, yeah.
You look at the infamous ones where it was like, a boyfriend
dies in the car crash, ASMR.
We were like reading them out.
Maybe.
no wait it's like
yeah and dies yeah those are fun like um the other day we
were like practicing toad voice and i was like trying to
songs in toad voice and people like you should just do that
as a voice pack and like never tell anybody that its toad
voice just like it should be an april fools thing you'd be
like matara matara comforts you when you had a bad day at
work asmr roleplay like hey there welcome home sweetie did
you have a good day at work
i'll rub your head
I bet you'll make so much money.
And they're like, no, now you're spoiling it, Doki.
Next time on April Fool's, guys, get ready.
That's right.
Yeah, I mean, Homer Simpson's fine with it.
He's fine with it.
No, she's more like that.
She's like, Tommy.
I can't do it that well.
Oh, no, am I getting noise gated?
Oh, yeah, you are.
You gotta turn that shit off.
Turn your noise gated off.
Hold on.
Let me try with...
Oh, noise gated.
Odge.
Yeah, turn that off.
Turn it off in Discord or no?
Um, I don't have noise gated on.
Custom voice isolation.
Just your beautiful voice.
Lead Discord cut through to noise.
Studio.
Open mic with no processing.
Okay, let me try the studio just to see.
Hello.
Hello, can you hear me?
Yeah, yeah, I can hear you.
Hello.
Mommy, I am your character, Ark.
Does it sound different for you, or does it sound the same
on Discord?
You sound a little quieter with that on, which I noticed.
All right, I don't know why.
I'll hold this back up.
That is weird.
have spilled um a lot of wine on my on my pc and like my my
little box that like has my noise gate and stuff so it is a
possibility that i i have messed things up for myself you
might need a new pc how do you spill it on your pc like well
well i mean like i've spilled it on my desk and then i have
like my vault which is kind of like where my microphone
plugs into yeah i've spilled it on that i actually needed a
new one a while back i'm hoping you know when when when we
move with my roommate like i'll be able to kind of like
reinstall a lot of my pc yeah yeah and just like do a full
kind of re kind of re-up things redo plus the problem is
where i live um in in the west coast there's a lot of cops
all the time and so even that gets noise gated and it's like
oh god you know freeze there's like the time when you come
back it's like dragon ball z it's like a dragon ball z cut
scene right there oh my god yeah it definitely must be must
be on my end then with i think so because i haven't had that
issue before so but like i wonder why yeah because like
because like if i'm fluid on your end because i'm fine on
your end right so but your signal you also get Okay, so it's
just signals.
It's literally just a Wi-Fi issue.
I do think, oh, the signals, like the aliens signaling.
Yeah.
Remember to wear your tinfoil hat, guys.
Do you believe in aliens?
I think there are aliens.
Like, there's no way we're the only people.
I mean, I'm an alien.
Yeah, there's no way, like, we're the only people on Earth,
you know?
There's like, well, also, like, if you're talking about
aliens on Earth, I don't know.
Right?
Oh, like, the other, yeah.
Yeah, but I don't think we're, like, it's like men in black.
situation they're among us right there but i'm pretty sure
there's alien like there's like beings on other planets
somewhere in the world in the galaxy you're telling me
there's this vast world out there and like there's you know
not been not been you know and only earth was able to create
life like that's that's bullshit yeah exactly yeah um i also
don't know if it's something that Like, I feel like when it
comes to worrying, you know, sometimes people are like,
aliens are going to come tomorrow and enslave us all and
kill us all.
I'm like, okay, but then if they do, like, I can't do
anything about it.
So why worry?
Like, it's like, where are you going to do?
Like if Genghis Khan rides at dawn, I don't have horse.
I don't have horse armor and horse archery.
I can't do anything about it.
I guess I'm going to die.
It's like, we're literally like, we're literally like the
cavemen to these aliens if they're going to come all the way
here to kill us.
it's you know it is what it is there's something i can do
about it so why worry your life yeah until the aliens come
and enslave us all yeah i will ride it might not even happen
in our lifetimes yeah that's true that's true i would rat
out my fellow fellow human beings for my alien overlord i
mean survival of the fittest guys and i'm here to survive I
think sometimes you got to remember that unless it's like
your really immediate friends and family, like most people
would do that to you as well.
Yeah, they're like, where are the humans hiding?
It's like over there, right down the street.
You know, this apartment building has 30 floors.
They're all 29 of them.
Yeah, they're all hiding on that one apartment building.
So don't worry, I got you guys.
And then they'll give me like a coupon for being good human.
I'm like, yay.
You get to like have one less probing or something.
probing card oh don't get on your high horse as if you won't
betray the human race if you get to live come on you want to
get probed brothers have killed each other for less exactly
like kings and every come on come on like unfortunately it's
just a matter of time until they find us anyway you're just
pro-lying it like Luckily, I'm doing you guys a favor for
getting, getting snitched out.
Oh, no, I, I, I definitely, I think, uh, you know, there's
got to be something out there and, and whether it's hostile
to us, not hostile, like, why worry, you know, like if, if
it's like, oh, one day I'm going to die.
I'm like, okay.
And cool.
One day I'm going to die.
You just live your life, you know, it's, yeah it better be a
good coupon not a group on oh it's like you and your
immediate like five friends get to like save on and on a
probing yeah just be like yeah skip the next probing oh what
if you could double and give it to the next person just
double it and give it to the next person yeah double the
probing you're so double the probing so sincere thinking
about your fellow mankind yeah and so like what if the
robots start taking over the world like what we're gonna do
about it like they already know all our information they're
always listening like i i i feel like okay it's hard for me
to remember too too far back because you know i'm a hag and
all that but i do feel like even looking at older cartoons
they were so much less stimulating than cartoons now yeah
older youtube video like sometimes i do feel like even for
myself i have just like i used to be able to study at the
library for hours oh true nothing but a starbucks and like a
lunch Now I need like my friends ringing me being like, are
you doing your job?
Are you on your task?
Do you find that as well?
Like it just gets harder to focus.
Get work.
Yeah.
Focus on games to focus on stuff in a way that I just can't
anymore.
It's a brain rot.
And then like the shorts because like now everybody just
watches shorts these days to get information.
I was telling my chat about how I've been like consuming
like certain anime series via just YouTube shorts.
Oh my God.
Or like, you know, TikTok when they're like, narrating the
movie oh yes because it's like you know there's no filler
it's just so direct and like you want it's like i used to
like but instead of watching movies i would just read the
wikipedia article of the movie just to see the plot and i
was like that's good enough for me i don't have to watch the
movie or anything i just i just read the wiki like i used to
do that and now i just use like youtube shorts for it i
think it's also like even with food i notice it because i
remember like you could not order food all the time like
yeah you can maybe order a pizza or like Chinese food but
now like you can get on you know uber eats or whatever
everything can be that's true everything's just convenient
we're becoming the wally guys the human the humans and wally
that's us i assume we're gonna you haven't seen wally before
the Pixar movie hello no no no i haven't seen it i was like
no no oh my god you see your model right now you see
yourself what's going on i was like are you okay what's that
slow bastard what what's going on i thought she's like she's
possessed the aliens are coming that's so i was like oh my
god are you okay i was like what oh no jackpot see time oh
she's gone all right i'm coming back let me in let me in
sorry i'm covering i'm covering myself i'm covering myself
she's like yeah she like gained sentience there in the
background put me in the background am i back am i back for
you hello hello hello you're well not on oh there you are oh
oh i'm coming back i'm loading back in here oh there's the
momo hey listen it's that's my there's the it's gotta be
still it still look laggy i don't know why you're like not
moving anymore i'm gonna talk to my computer tech about this
because this is really strange like even when i left your
model on my studio was like super kind of like moving fast
and laggy yeah i wonder why oh my god it looks like i'm
hugging you with my other claw oh yeah it does like i'm like
come here girl yeah come on take that shot with me girl and
so it's like She's becoming self-aware.
Wait, we were talking about what we were talking about.
I don't remember.
AI overlords.
I feel like it wasn't like, I think panda bears or something
like, or maybe it's like red panda bears.
They don't like procreate anymore.
Yeah, regular.
You kind of have to force them to procreate.
Yeah.
I told my chat about it.
I was like, if it wasn't for the fact that panda is pretty
privileged, they'd be dead already.
Yeah.
everybody just thinks they're cute so they're like please
like we need more of them they're so cute if they didn't
have pretty privilege they'd be extinct by now they're just
too cute like i told them how like uh they show pandas porn
just to force them to get into like the moon you know that
they show panda porn to pandas so they show pandas panda
porn yeah they're like to get them into the mood to be like
that's how you do it guys yeah there's here's some panda
porn like they watch like videos of other pandas like doing
it where it's like the pandas are like oh actually i prefer
when it's like this type of you know i prefer when they're
like a couple i prefer when they're like you know crossing
the boundary a little bit i prefer when like she's wearing a
cute outfit or like oh i want to like do you think pandas
can get cucked or something like i prefer watching like i
want to watch i want to watch instead of doing it like get
him a chair
actually i like it when it's two male pandas together like
the panda tag the tag pandas have certain fetishes and kinks
guys like we gotta they might you guys like you guys are
judging but like realistically you know logistically
realistically cannibalistically they might have yeah we
don't know what they're thinking they might actually have
preference references what if we just couldn't replicate the
perfect like what they want you know we don't know their
tags What if we need to see, like, you know, what if the
panda's like, I need to see woman on woman?
They want to see panda Yuri.
They're like, they're like, I want this panda to choke me.
They're like, I want this panda to put their perpaws on my
neck.
I want this panda to call me a good girl.
he's like he's like daddy
freaky panda yeah what if they're like not getting like they
probably have like two couples left of pandas that can
reproduce what if they just haven't like you know just
vanilla panda yeah yeah they just need
Yeah.
Oh, also, like, apparently, panda, pandas, uh, my dragons
know about this, but, um, pandas, uh, they don't understand
the concept of twins.
So, like, so because, like, so every time a panda has more
than one child, um, they have to, like, swap the baby
pandas, like, like, while, like, they have to distract the
mama panda and then swap them, um, because the, the mama
panic can't understand that there's more than one baby so
like if there's more than one baby she'll be like what the
fuck is that other baby doing here who is that what were
they called like um angelings changelings something like
that oh changelings yeah yeah like the the skinwalkers like
is this a fairy like yeah yeah yeah like the mom will ignore
the second baby if like if they're if she gets like twins or
anything so they have to like swap the babies in and out
every day just so like the mom can be like can give
attention to them underappreciated by your parents just
remember that the panda mother will literally ignore the
twin i will literally ignore you she does have a favorite
like does oh my god i feel like humans are kind of like on
the way you know since i live inside a human woman i'm
noticing that like human it's just everything sorry
but i i infest a human woman oh yeah yeah she's been
streaming on twitch television she speaks a few languages
she's a little cutie-padooty you know i was like oh this
this would be a parasite i'm a parasite you are you're like
that i've heard she's my she's like that brain worm you know
that i am yeah yeah yeah that brain worm in the brain you're
here yeah i am yeah go on but i do notice it like and
sometimes it's hard to remember because i'm just trying to
remember if like it was always like this because you know
sometimes it's hard to remember the past because you see it
through a filter kind of you like you remember the past
slightly differently but i definitely do notice that yeah
like ordering food always having even music like it used to
be to listen to music you had to like bring a big disc man
with you around yeah mp3 player this was pre mp3 player
right like it was a lot if you cd scratch you listen now you
just have constant stimulation all the time that's so true i
think it's also like news in general too like news articles
and like news updates it's always like constant news coming
in whether it's like bad or good and you just get like
desensitized to it oh yeah oh yeah that's definitely um yeah
i i do wonder if like humans were kind of going into that
path of like yeah you're just gonna you know like i'm gonna
like Like tonight, I'm going to sit down and order probably
some, I don't know, tacos later and drink my wine and hang
out with you.
It's, yeah.
I'm on my second bottle, my second can now.
Let's go.
I'm having a little orange wine.
I saw it.
Let's talk is orange, which means the time of oranges.
Nice.
And it's a French wine.
It's an orange wine, Beaujolais, 100% Chardonnay, 100%
Chardonnay.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
You're basically fluent in French, so don't worry about it.
I used to be.
And then I forgot it all.
I cheated on my French exam to graduate.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Back in the good old days, I kind of want people to
understand cheating was very different back then.
It was very easy to do.
On my eraser.
Yeah.
I used to write things on a piece of paper, put it in my
shoe, then just take it out and put it like under my paper.
Oh my God.
That's okay.
So, all right.
It's okay.
can't take my degree away.
It passed the laws of what was it called?
It's passed the where like after a while I think it's like
after five years they can't trial you for like small petty
crime.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a word for it.
Laws of something something.
It starts with an S but I don't remember what it was called.
But anyway, they can't do it.
It's too late.
The years are gone.
Oh yeah, the statue of limitations.
Yeah.
Past the statue of limitations.
Okay, so mine was super big.
big brain so um it was like uh it was a French exam
obviously an examination room with all these other people
and uh you know your like desks are all lined up like it was
in the gym and desks are all lined up it's exam exam time in
high school for senior year and I needed to pass this French
exam to like have a passing grade technically so um because
I the the degree I did in high school was international
baccalaureate and it's like one of the ib programs it's one
of the hardest i also wasn't that yes you know how it's like
one of the hardest programs project baby yeah i had to do
that and like i was really worried because i failed my
french exam like it's gonna up like it's gonna me over
because everything else i'm fine it was just french because
i hated my french
what I did was we can bring a dictionary, a French English
to English or English to French dictionary with us.
It's a really tiny book.
Just put a bunch of stuff in it.
No.
Okay.
So what I did to not get caught is I scanned the dictionary
pages.
It's a very tiny dictionary.
It's not like those giant dictionaries.
It's like those little mini like those like tiny one books
ones.
And then because like there's also a size limit to how big
the dictionary can be when you bring in to the exams it's
like you know people are like oh we don't want like you know
to like slip stuff in so what i did i scanned the page of
the dictionary and so we're also given questions like these
there's gonna be they gave us five questions in preparation
for the exam but the in the exam they'll pick two of these
questions so for your essays so um i basically wrote four
essays in preparation.
I wrote four essays.
And what I did is I scanned the dictionary page.
And in Photoshop, I copy and pasted my exam answer, like the
essay answer, into the dictionary.
But I followed the dictionary format.
So it looked like it was its own.
Oh, so you literally like put a page, like a fake page in
almost.
And then I just, and I cut it up and glued it onto the
dictionary page to look like it was part of the dictionary.
So if I'm at the dictionary i can just read like literally
just copy and paste it the like copy and paste whatever i
wrote in the dictionary onto the onto the uh exam yeah i
pre-loaded the essay like it literally looked like it was
part of the dictionary like the font like i literally got
the exact font the colors the format everything because i
had a program that could tell me what the font is that was
used and everything.
And then, so I was just like, who cares about memorizing?
Like, I'm not going to memorize five different, like,
essays.
I don't know.
Let's be honest.
You're going to forget about it in like a week.
You're going to forget about it.
It's just how it works.
And then it was, like, so funny because the French teacher
was like, because, like, he didn't know why I wrote on the
essay, obviously, but, like, he got the result and he was
like, I didn't think you would get such a good score on your
essay.
Congratulations, you must have worked really, really hard.
And I was like, yeah, yep, I did.
Merci beaucoup, monsieur.
Merci beaucoup.
Exactly.
Oui, oui.
Oui, beau, professor.
Yeah, I did it.
Yes, French.
You know, nowadays, you can actually like get a calculator.
Yeah.
That's been like whatever they're called like, you know, you
could do it with like a jailbreak, lockbreak, whatever.
You can jailbreak your calculator and put Chad GPT or claw
on it.
What?
Yes.
Oh my.
No, you know what?
That's crazy.
You're jailbreaking your calculator for that.
Yeah.
And you can like actually like do stuff on the clawed.
And I'm like, what the heck?
where was this at my like yeah where's my chat gpt yeah i
heard people are banning google like they they're they're
making sure like students don't come in wearing google
glasses because people would like search up the answers on
their glasses and stuff so they have to like examine every
student's glasses before they take an exam problem in
casinos that like oh that's true i saw that too recognize it
but some of them don't and like people come in in glasses
and ai is like yeah like how oh you hear about uh how
universities right now are having problems with how ai like
use people use students using ai to finish their uh projects
and stuff so like for like essay checkers and everything so
you know how like back in the day back in the day university
we used turn it in uh to avoid plagiarism we didn't have ai
to to like help us right everybody would be like wait did
you just copy paste this like yeah yeah so copy paste this
from the wikipedia yeah yeah like You plagiarized this from
this exam or this study.
You didn't use it in your own words.
But nowadays, students will just use ChatGPT or some AI
program to write their entire essay and everything.
But apparently, universities, to combat that, they have
their own AI program to see if their paper is written by AI.
But the thing is, some of those programs can be wrong, you
know?
Like, they don't 100%.
Are you saying AI, our God and Savior, can be wrong
sometimes?
No way, that can't be.
Apparently.
Yeah, they're listening dokey.
They're listening I'm listening She knows too much don't
stand near a window dokey don't You hear about that how like
a lot of assassinations are done via windows Yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, they're like they're not like they stop they're
just like it works, you know It's just it's very convenient.
They just somehow for some reason wow, they were so clumsy
to a window like yeah just you know dokey bird who like had
never any you know bad yeah yeah so clumsy dokey yeah such a
clumsy little bird um but yeah there's like cases right now
where um universities are trying to use ai to combat ai and
some students who actually did write their own essays
they're being like uh flagged as like ai yeah unfairly yeah
and they're like i literally they're like, you can literally
see in my, like, because they would soon start writing on
Google Doc now, because Google Doc tracks every change in
everything you type.
Oh, they you make.
Yeah.
So it's like a way to come back against AI accusations.
So if a professor says you got flagged for AI, you can be
like, no, check my Google Doc.
It literally tracks every typo, every change.
Yeah.
Oh, interesting.
So, So I think I mean, that's like a nice way to come back
against AI accusations, too.
Oh, my God.
I don't know how like, I wonder about this now, like if
you're in school now, how like, I don't know how to phrase
this thought, but I don't know.
It just feels like weird to why would you learn anything
when there's AI?
And I know even back in like my little thing.
Yeah, but it's dumbing us down though, for real.
is yeah even in my good old days it was like well why would
i learn this there's a calculator why would i learn that
there's a this and and it's true i'll be honest like yes i
have basic math but calculator does a lot of work that's
true okay i would yeah i agree fuck math
i'm a man i'm an auntie
oh my god come on come on math math no no fuck numbers well
i have a i have a four and calculate why am i ever gonna use
trigonometry guys yeah i don't even know what the square
root of the pittagorean triangle why pitharius yeah
pittagorean is that a real word
no no there's definitely stuff that i feel like i'm glad i
learned and i'm glad i did but it does make me wonder like
if i was a kid today yeah i heard it being a teacher fucking
sucks now apparently because there's more there's more work
being put into being a teacher when it comes to like
checking for ai because like ai is just being like the bane
of every teacher's existence and also very overprotective
parents apparently overprotective parents and also i have a
few friends who are teachers that many of them quit um the
kids are just so much more yeah yeah no offense if you're a
child listening right now you suck yeah Yeah, that's right.
Don't worry.
It gets better though.
It gets better.
It does get better.
Just now you're 35, it gets even better.
Yeah, just now you're a little shit right now.
No one likes you.
You are.
You don't have empathy.
You don't know shit.
Okay.
You're an idiot.
But it actually is apparently getting so much worse where
kids are just like so much more aggressive, so much more
mean.
They have even less like content created.
I think it's because they're exposed to a lot of like the
internet now.
And it's very easy to like watch like content created.
that encourages like really bad behavior as well.
Like don't be pervert.
Like me, yeah, if you're watching me as a child, actually
don't do that.
It's even like, you know, back in the, back in my time, for
example, like you went outside, you did a bunch of stuff.
I know, I know grandma used to walk to school, you know,
five kilometers, whatever.
I used to walk 80 miles.
Exactly.
But now like you get home and your parents just hand you the
iPad and then you come to school and now you're not allowed
the iPad because it's an addiction yeah your brain is
addicted to the dopamine of scrolling and the fortnight and
everything yeah and i heard when you come to school and
you're like i also read that like uh i know it's it's no
back then back in the day when i used to read yeah i'm just
regurgitating all the content that i used to read uh uh i
also read like uh because of ipads and stuff it's actually
like hindering development of a child's brain because of it
too i believe it yeah like i always quote the study but you
should never show your kid coco melon because studies have
shown that like coco melon actually like makes kids dumber
like there's also like i watched the video about it and how
like i i agree with her how there's no kid friendly space in
on the internet anymore compared to when like we were
growing up back then But then we had like TV and we had
stuff like that, I guess.
But I wonder if kids don't even watch TV anymore, too.
Yeah.
I wonder if it's because like now everything is like,
everything is a bit, like obviously, you know, they have
like cartoons to sell toys and stuff like that.
But now it's like the YouTube videos.
I don't know.
It's also like toys as well.
I've noticed that toys are just gotcha systems now.
There's no actual toy toy.
It's just gotcha and getting that burst of dopamine.
then that's it for the child.
That's your toy.
You get like that's one use thing and then you have to buy
something new because I love capitalism.
I have to tell you something.
So one of my friends just got into basketball and they and
because they got into basketball, they're telling me about
all the basketball stuff.
Yeah.
Basketball.
Okay.
So they're releasing a pair of shoes, right?
For basketball.
Usually it's like simple.
Like let's say like Doki Bird and Nike.
Yeah.
And it's like the Doki Bird colored shoe for Nike.
You can buy it.
It sells out, whatever.
be it's limited edition but these shoes that are getting
released uh i forget if it's for kobe or lebron i apologize
guys i'm not well one one no no wait he said that the shoe
releasing what happens now is they're actually having 13
different shoes with one of them being a rare yeah basically
oh yeah gotcha and like each of them is literally the
difference just so we're clear is that the is in in blue or
in red or in or in whatever but then the even shoes are like
gotcha yeah even the even the shoes and then my friends like
well you know i kind of want to buy them i'm like well maybe
like if you like you have a sibling with shoe size or
something hold on let me find let me find this shoe i'm
gonna see if i have this in the conversation yeah like the i
was like what do you mean they're doing gotcha for like nba
shoes like that that's that's crazy it is that like shoes of
odd things like Nike shoe collabs that that's like I don't
know it just gave me such a like yeah and then like there's
okay oh there we go Nike's dropping 14 pair of Kobe's as a
mystery blind bag release okay here I'll copy the link I'll
send it to you it's like on Instagram yeah yeah I mean you
posted a chat too but um hold on yeah let me let me send it
into the chat for them sorry everybody you need an instagram
account for 40 pairs that's crazy um but basically you like
buy this box and you just hope that you get yeah but they
like you know
yeah that's actually that's fucked yeah what do you mean
you're like gotcha-fying shoes like you don't come in and
you're like i want this shoe in blue and red and they'll
like sorry buddy you gotta get a box and i get it in blue
and yellow blue and red like hello yeah shoes they're
literally shoes yeah so it's it's just like like why is that
why are we going to the point where we're gotching shoes and
the shoes are just in a different color like like don't get
me wrong i understand gotching like like for example i just
got nichi's um uh merch drop and in it she had like a little
uh gotcha box for jared which is her mascot and it was like
little little like um poses of jared so like i got a
different kind of like a libu yeah but that's gotcha a nike
shoe yeah but that's that's like not that's like cheaper too
because it's it's like you're not paying like a hundred plus
dollars for it exactly that's where it gets a little bit
like you know what do you mean i'm gotching like a shoe to a
shoe a shoe yeah it's a little Oh, that's why like when it
comes to shoes or even shirts, I'd be like shirts like, I
don't know.
Yeah.
And yeah.
And that's another thing about the shoes.
They're all the same.
They just have a different color.
Like it's either green, blue, and then one of them is the
ultra rare.
We're like, you know, come on.
It's just like, it's just, I think like we're going too far
with loot boxes and gotcha now, like blind boxes in general.
Like everybody just wants to like that little of being like
oh what's inside this little box i'm getting and then you
just don't care i i have a problem with blind boxes by the
way oh you tell me everything i i i i will say i'm a victim
i'm a victim of all of this it's not my fault i was a victim
okay okay in your defense all jokes aside like no there is
actually people that are like a million times smarter than
us that have like create it and refine this system of
gambling through Las Vegas through wine boxes like yes no
you are correct but I am still gonna laugh go on sorry yeah
so this is why I don't gamble or like do gotcha games
because like I know I have a very addicting personality
because if I ever get hooked on something I addictive yeah
yeah I'm very addictive personality right so yeah yeah but
So that's why I try to avoid gambling.
Like, I never gambled before, and I've never, like, I've
never, like, done, like, committed to a gacha game.
Never gambled before?
Nope.
Never been to a casino or anything.
Never done slots or anything.
Never played cards.
The first time I ever played poker was for the poker night
at inventory game, which was, like, two to three months ago.
That was the very first time I've ever played poker ever.
I didn't even know what the rules of poker were.
Did you guys play Holden?
Do you remember what?
poker was um well we it was the name poker night at the
inventory i don't even know what poker i was playing it was
poker it was like online it was like uh it was just a steam
game um released made by valve um we were just playing poker
against like some of their valve character balatro yeah you
were just playing balatro and you're like i don't know what
kind of poker this is it includes like getting a trillion
points that too i was i played palatro i was like they're
like it's didn't my chat was just like it's like poker it's
like i've never played poker contest I was like I don't know
what the how the fuck do you play but lotro and they're like
don't worry it's just like poker I'm like what do you mean
so basically when I was young my parents would let me do
their scratch and win lottery tickets when I was like since
I was like a little baby like like three years old when I
can hold a penny in my hand and be like scratch scratch I
got addicted to that I got really addicted to this and he
started me off young so at like grocery store, I'd be like,
can you buy me a scratch and win ticket?
And they're like, let's buy you a scratch and win ticket.
They'll give me a loony and then I start scratching.
Oh, she knows loonies.
Yeah, yeah.
So...
Dollar for all of you non-Canadian.
Yeah.
And it's got a loon on it.
So every time in the grocery store or at the market, they
always buy me one scratch and win ticket.
And as a little kid, I would get this rush whenever I
scratch the ticket.
And I'm like, I got two dollars.
Yeah.
Anyway.
And then growing up for, when I was growing up in elementary
school, my mom would always buy me a little blind box to put
in with my lunch.
So every time after I finish eating, I'll open up my little
blind box and be like, look at me.
I got a Nyasha figure.
I got a little Nyasha toy.
Look at me go.
Switching again, by the way.
Don't, don't worry.
Yeah.
So let it ride.
as a kid i was like you lit it right um that's cute but it
was not healthy yes so then that started my addiction off of
blind boxes so every time i get there's a blind like where i
can there's a place where i can buy a blind box i would buy
a blind box and so i have a lot of blind boxes i actually
have some i haven't opened yet because i've been saving it
up for whenever i do a potentially little head yeah i wanted
a hand cam where i would i want to open all these blind
on hold on i have to pee all right i have to pee one minute
one moment i'll be right back bye-bye matara anyway yeah so
i was molded by the gotcha so i have like a bunch of blind
boxes i bought from japan last time um and also oh there she
is oh there she goes
It's like she's swapping clothes, guys.
Every time she's gone, she's in the bathroom.
She's just changing her outfit.
Is that, like, the size of my face?
There it is.
So, I have a bunch of blind boxes.
Even ones that I got from LA, too.
Yeah, I just do the nap.
Gotcha.
But I get really addicted to blind boxes.
And that's why I don't gamble and I don't do gotcha games
Because I know if whenever I ever do do any of these things
It'll be very bad It would be very, very bad Yeah, Matara's
also gotcha right now We're gotcha in her outfits at the
moment See, that's why gambling's bad
Or you could become really rich and rich.
Oh, that's true.
Wait, he makes a good point, guys.
So I was like, that's why I was like, that's why I don't
gamble.
And so I was like, oh, you could be really, really rich
though.
And I'm like, you're right.
I feel like with gambling, though, I...
Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
I hear the police outside.
I feel like with gambling, what I really like, they are is
like low stakes gambling where it's like oh make a little
bet with my friend of like oh 20 bucks says this da da da da
five gifted says that especially games like 10 gift it says
that you used to do poker though right yeah i did yeah i
wasn't very good at it but i did wait you weren't i thought
you were you didn't say you did i thought i so okay i think
i was a professional poker player no are you kidding me you
weren't not anywhere anywhere close.
So the problem with poker, it's kind of the same.
I wonder if you have the same problem with Apex and
Overwatch, people get better.
Yeah, of course, because that's the skill level improves.
Number one, number two, my own mental is getting worse and
worse and worse.
And I'm just really bad at like, even if you do everything
optimally, there's still a place in there that I just don't
love.
I just don't have the mental fortitude for it.
Well, you're cutting in and out right now.
I don't know if it's like.
My God, what's up with my internet?
Yeah, that's who you're like cutting in and out.
I was like, what the fuck?
I'm glad you didn't stream.
It must be something on my, me too.
It must be something on my end.
I'm gonna have to talk to my, to my, um.
Yeah, they cut the lines.
They heard, they heard.
Yeah, they're hearing right now.
They're cutting our lines.
It was the AI.
It's because you said AI is bad and they were like, oh,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
But then they, they got the wrong person.
they were like oh it's her they lost the 50 50.
yeah no i i really don't like the the most i'll do now with
gambling is i'll play like a little bit of blackjack yeah
i'll drink and i'll just have fun with it but um i do wonder
what it's like like with i don't know if you know this now
but everybody's betting on everything oh yeah yes poly
market yeah yeah i saw one where like will jesus christ come
back before gta 6.
yeah i don't know we don't know we got a bet on it we got a
bet the return of christ yeah before gta 6.
don't put them in for you at the poly market don't worry
i'll gamble for you guys so i'll i'll be out so you guys
won't have to i'll sacrifice myself for you guys your money
right like the hedge funds and whatever this is like that
Like, Doki is a consummate gambler.
Let her invest your...
Yeah, enable me.
Yeah, don't worry.
I'll be the one to take on your bad habits, guys.
I will gamble for your sins.
Yeah.
No, it's definitely a scary thing.
And, like, I cannot imagine, like, having my...
Like, listen, I'm a grown adult.
I'm, like, a very grown adult.
Like, I've been paying my taxes for a damn long time.
I'm the kind of adult where, like, I can have adult
children.
you know and yeah um even myself i catch myself falling into
like the dopamine trap and the alcohol trap and the junk
food trap and like that i'm like oh imagine how yo-lo yo-lo
hashtag yo-lo guys am i right yo-lo look at that you're
getting all the please make sure to invest their money and
make sure they get all good returns of course guys but like
there are interest rates guys you do know of course yeah I
got to take a hard cut there's an interest rates there is
GST tax there's uh the the the tax the stream tax there's
the super chat tax um there's the Matara tax because she's
here so that there's a double here I deserve 10 yeah exactly
um and there's also also it's weird my capture is working on
my side because I saw somebody write it is just not working
on your i'll have to talk to my well your capture is what
some people like my capture is absolutely working on my side
yeah but like i me on your me on your side is up so it's
just the internet signals between us it is it is yeah
there's there's oceans in between yeah we're so far oh my
god i'm like going super sane again yeah i'm gonna use You
can talk to the mommos and dragoons.
I'll be back.
I love your goods.
Are you having fun?
Doki's being a little drunky and cute.
How y'all feeling?
How y'all doing?
I'm really glad she invited.
Honestly, I told her today, I was like, hey, I think I can
do a game.
Mentally, physically, spiritually, I'm fried.
I've been crying a lot.
I was just scared to, you know, cry.
And then she's like, hey, you know, I think you need some
company.
She's like, let's just...
to hang out and yap let's just let's just chill let's like
have a drink and so when i hear that a non-drinker is going
to be breaking out the drink something i gotta be here for
you girl uh but yeah she i very much appreciate it very very
good it's fun i'm so sorry my capture isn't working i
honestly have no idea why that could be um i have pretty
good internet pretty good everything but i did notice that
it's been kind of weird for a while now um so i I wonder if
it's just like where I live and doing.
Yeah.
I know Doki looks so small and cute.
I know she's so small.
Too little Doki.
But yeah.
Also, I will have you all know.
She already did agree, but I will say it now so she can take
it back.
She will be coming.
I will be revamping my podcast.
Be coming back up and she will, yes, expect these kinds of
conversations.
maybe not the panda one i do think it's it's a really great
bit to think about like you know what if they're just
showing the pandas the wrong kind of pornography like what
if that's just not the kind of pornography that they're into
so because of that they're like sorry i i came from create
that's not the kind of stuff i like to
see that's just not the kind of stuff i like to see you know
so yeah and i I wonder how you could like eventually figure
out what kind of stuff they'd wanna see.
I don't know.
You never know.
You truly never know.
Are you guys gonna miss her?
She's going on a little work trip.
What are you guys gonna miss?
Ooh, ooh.
Yeah, all the everybody crying.
Yeah, we're gonna miss her.
Miss her so bad.
We're going to miss her so much.
Missing her already.
I like that cry.
Cry.
Miss her and cry.
Oh, she's back.
She's moving.
She's awakening.
Her spirits are stirring.
My spirit's back in my body.
I'm making them cry because I'm like, are you guys going to
miss her?
Oh, no.
Why would you say that?
She's like, she'll never come back.
And then she never comes back.
She's never going to come back.
Tari's just gonna never gonna it's a never-ending stream and
Tari's just gonna keep talking he's like where did she go
like the AI is gonna when she's on her trip the AI overlords
are gonna get her she's never gonna be back yeah she's gonna
stand next to a window
she's gonna take the elevator and down in a burning building
yeah yet again i was like that should be fine worked last
time but like knocking on wood please legally speaking don't
die in like the next week or so legally speaking please
don't die in the next week or so because like the cops will
be coming to my apartment and i'm currently like the person
the last person she talked to yeah guys if anything happens
please contact matara con first so big oh you girls joked
about her getting sniped from a window well well well guys
the last person i've ever talked to before i go on my trip
was matara Please make sure to like DM mint tonight and
lime.
And then and then nope, just you.
Nope, I will not talk to anyone else after this stream of my
business trip.
And I will snap next to every single window.
And I'll put a little arrow that says like aim here.
It's like the the what was it like at post Epstein.
People were like, I I'll be like, oh, I do not wish to kill
myself at all.
Perfectly good mental health and physical health right now
But I was talking to Matara Khan last time so if anything
happens to me Matara will be my first point of contact If
you die, can I get 20 bucks?
I mean, I'm dead.
You can fucking take my wallet right?
If I'm dead, you can break into my house if you want to I
won't be there You know what?
You know what?
There's a window.
No, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
No, I don't want 20 bucks.
I'd rather you stay alive at least until you talk to other
people.
You can bet on my life on Polymarket before I go.
Wait, what a great bet.
Do you guys think she'll come back from her trip?
Will Tokey Bear return from her trip?
Live on Polymarket right now.
Spark your butt right now in the super chat.
just remember just remember to all the fbi and the the art
where's the raw rc or rcmp that are listening right now rcmp
and the fbi that's listening to you right now matara is
encouraging a polymarket bet of my life right now in
minecraft yeah yeah the minecraft game bar yeah yeah that's
right not the rcmp yeah the royal canadian mountain police
they're watching they are always they're always watching the
least expected that i did hear about that that um apparently
like people were inside like gambling on on like wars and
stuff oh yeah yeah the insider trading everything is
gambling about we can all gamble on everything do you have
do you have any pets matara i never know i don't because i i
travel a lot and um i i get into these like really bad bad
like not leaving the house for three days so i feel like if
i had a pet i would be just not a great but wouldn't like
the pet encourage you to leave leave like go outside more
maybe it may be but also until i get like a permanent living
situation yeah i just can't and also it doesn't help so i'm
very close so my parents come visit me a lot and yeah
they're one of them is allergic to pets like and we tried to
explain that like no no we can get a cat or a dog that like
you won't be allergic to but he's an old man so it's like no
i am allergic to kit you will know what i mean how do i
explain it to him yeah tell me about your pet tell me about
dad dad he's a little that's what he's just a crazy little
shit i mean hey you know what they say like pet like owner
you know no no i'm a perfect angel i don't know where he
gets it from i'm scared to have a dog that just becomes an
alcoholic you know i can't have that he just gives him vodka
yeah like how did you do that how did you like he's a like
dog like the dog weed or whatever it is yeah so like dad
he's like basically he's learned my streaming voice
basically so he knows when when I'm streaming and he uses
that to he takes uses that to his advantage like he gets me
when I'm vulnerable because the thing is he knows that he's
not supposed to be barking because I've had noise complaints
before and so I I can't just like let him keep barking
because I've if I do that people will report on me um so
what he does and is that uh when I start stream and when I
start
trying to get food because he knows you're gonna have to
give it to him yeah like that's the only way for him to stop
barking so because he would he would try to get food early
so like he tries to go but like he tries to go early in the
schedule of his feeding schedule so i what i have to do is i
have to feed him like little bits because i don't want to
feed him like dinner at like 3 p.m so because you know he's
gonna ask for it again when you go live at 5 p.m yeah no
like when i keep
what he does is that like basically he'll just bark and then
I have to give him a treat one because I always limit to one
treat per day so he barks he gets his treat and then he
barks he gets a little bit of his food and then he barks and
then I feed the rest of his dinner after like one it's like
two to three hours because I'm like now it's dinner time so
I can give him his dinner um and then but the thing is the
moment I'm on a rest day and I'm still on my PC like I'm
still working on my PC he won't bark he would just sleep
because he doesn't hear Oh my God.
Because he doesn't hear me streaming.
He doesn't, he knows that I'm not streaming anymore because
I'm on my PC working.
But he only does it whenever I'm streaming.
He even knows when I end stream.
Because like the moment I go into like the whole like, you
know, get up and move around and get that blood flow.
Like he knows that lot, like tag a lot, like my whole outro.
And he will start barking.
Because he's like, I know, I know your stream's ending.
Adoki.
I know, you can feed me.
I know.
I know your stream's ending, so you have to give me food
now.
Yeah, you're supposed to train him, not the other way
around.
Yeah, he's trained me.
Yeah.
He knows.
He knows what I'm most vulnerable.
How long have you had him?
He's like eight now.
He's eight years old.
Yeah, but he's like, he's so smart.
Yeah, I found out apparently, like, because like mine, like,
obviously he's a guy.
Apparently, like female wiener dogs are more chill, the more
they the more pup like they still stay puppy like so the
female weiner dogs they mature faster so the older they get
the more like docile they are the more mature like like
chill they are they don't need like they don't have a lot as
much energy as they're younger but male dogs apparently he
they they stay puppy like for like majority of their life so
it doesn't seem like they're like older oh that's so cute
yeah i love it also somebody being like oh you're like
you're not supposed to give in to try resisting those big
puppy eyes that's true you think you're so good being like
you just resist oh come on yeah also i don't want to get
kicked out of my apartment that too the fact that your dog
knows that you're like busy with work yeah like your dog has
managed to figure that out be like all right i can i can oh
he's like how does he feel no yeah I was just saying he's
just he just knows he just knows whenever it's whenever I
stream and now he knows when to get me how does he feel
about outfits is he into them does he mind them too he
doesn't really care you know how some dogs will try to take
it off when he has the outfit on he's just like all right
he's like whatever all right I guess that's on me now I like
that I like when they're like you know what I gotta do what
I gotta do I just
yeah just that that little rascal what made you decide to
get that breed of dog oh I grew up with him like I grew up
with these types of dog breeds um so I remember my very
first because like um I had another when I was growing up I
had like a where's the call I always keep forgetting that
type of dog breeds like those like big white fluffy dog
started like the Eskimo dogs yes yeah yeah yeah yeah Samoyas
yeah yeah so but my parents got him when I was born so they
were he was like the dog I grew up with but then I wanted my
own dog like an inside dog because he was not allowed in the
house so yeah because he's so fluffy yeah he's so fluffy and
big so he was always an outside dog so um so uh I begged
when I was growing up I begged my parents when I was a
little kid that I really wanted inside dog so I can play
with him inside I want my own dog because the Samoya was my
parents dog So then when we went to the pet store back when
we didn't know buying from pet stores was really bad Back
when you know back in the good old days.
We didn't know about puppy mills guys We didn't know
cigarettes were bad for us.
We didn't know anything about puppy mills.
They put dogs at the dog store I buy dogs at a pet store.
How is I supposed to know that?
But now I know, okay?
Now I know.
Okay, so anyway.
So we went to the pet store.
And then, you know, I saw, like, I saw a weenered dog there.
And obviously I was like, it was like a really cute dog
breed.
It was a miniature weenered dog.
And I really liked the colors.
And then I was like, I want that one.
And then it was from there, I realized that I just really
like that particular dog breed.
Just like how they look because they're so long and short.
Yeah, they're so skinny.
And I feel like they have such a wild personality, too, in
general.
Because they love to, they love to burrow.
So because they wouldn't always, they know how to, they
basically know how to tuck themselves in.
If you give them a blanket, they know how to tuck themselves
in with a blanket.
That's actually so cute.
What the heck?
Yeah, yeah.
It's like so fucking cute.
It's like no other dogs really do that.
I remember when we were...
Child gambler, foie gras, apologist, puppy milk patient.
She does it all.
That's Yoroshi.
Also, Jay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Today is my birthday.
But I've been prepping for AX Iris Valley all day.
Will I be able to get a happy birthday from you?
Of course, you get a happy birthday from both of us.
Happy birthday, Jay.
Do you think we can sync up our birthday song to him?
We can do this, right?
Oh, sure for her.
Okay, you can start, I'll follow along.
Okay, three, two, one.
Happy birthday to Jay.
Oh, oh, wait, no, wait, to you.
Sorry, to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jay.
Yay!
Sorry, I had my, um, I had my little toad voice coming in.
Yeah, I am.
Anyway, yeah, so not a lot of dogs know how to tuck
themselves in.
I remember when we, for our first dog, his name was Bobo.
Um, and he, when we had him like taken to a dog hotel or
have someone else look different, they were always like,
your dog knows to tuck himself in.
That's crazy.
We're like, oh my God, it's so wild to see.
it's like from my first dog it was when i was like i want to
own wiener dogs for the rest of my life like i want to be a
wiener dog mom like cat lady i want to be a wiener dog lady
yeah i like that yeah you know what you're about but like
it's crazy because like whenever you get a wiener dog it's
like a thing apparently in a wiener dog community i know
there's a wiener dog community but me and my homies at the
wiener community yeah the wiener dog group yeah yeah like
it's very exclusive no it's true though because like when
you it's like I say when you get weenered dog you don't go
back like you're like a lot of people who get weenered dog
they always get weenered dogs because there's just something
about them like you're like they're like a weenered dog mom
um so so it's like the weenered dog society yeah so it was
like I I just really love that type of dog breed and
everything so that's why I like own like three i think i've
owned like um this is my third wiener dog basically that's a
lot of wiener dogs yeah it's a lot of wienies that is i
almost bought it yeah oh wait what are you gonna say you
almost bought a sibling for dad i almost bought a second
wiener dog two days ago i was so tempted what like what
brought you into it what got you out of it no i was just
like i want another weener dog i would it's just like like
you know taking care of one animal isn't enough okay it is
actually it's actually enough but the thing is i feel really
bad because i've been working a lot so i figured like he had
another sibling he would have someone to play with like true
yeah yeah but then and i was like i i told this to my
manager before i was just like uh what if i get another
weiner dog because like if he's barking he won't be barking
anymore because him he would like he would just play with
the other dog.
And they'll totally be barking.
And then my manager brought that up.
What if he teaches the other dog to bark at you?
And then you'll have two problems.
I was like, oh, that's true.
You're basically like trained him as an employee at the
restaurant.
I'm like, all right, all right.
So you're not supposed to do this, but this is how I do
this.
So you see when the manager's out there, you take out your
phone and you triple quadruple.
So you prank call the restaurant and you order a pizza and
then they return it and we get a free.
Oh, you get a free.
Oh, that is smart.
That is.
Yeah.
So I almost because like it all.
Also, there was a really cute, like, it would have broke my
black and tan color of weeners because I always get the
black and tan weeners, too, because there's just something
about that color scheme that I really, really like.
But then I saw someone was selling a dappled weener dog, a
short-haired dappled weener dog.
So I don't know, you know, dappled.
It's like, it's like bluish, bluish dots.
It's really pretty.
I find...
Oh, it looks so...
Stop!
Yeah, it's so pretty.
So I saw that and I was so, I was so close to, to contact,
to texting them and being like, hello, I heard you were
selling another Wiener Dog.
That is so cute, actually.
Oh my God.
Yeah, like the little dots and stuff.
I don't know.
It's just the, I just, the color scheme is really cute.
So I was like, I've never owned a dappled colored Wiener Dog
before.
So it's like a shiny.
Exactly.
It's a shiny.
since my capture very much has given out can we just do fugi
for oh yeah because like why am i even i've been i've been
doing the capture for a while like why am i even doing it
like at this point you know it's it's boogie time i wonder
if your steam has been updating a game this entire time
wouldn't that be funny my god path of exile 2 is updating
but not only one game but still no no but it's that i think
it's other stuff no wait turn up the update it could be
because steam to throw it on my internet yeah has it been
updating this entire time i don't think it has because like
my internet's pretty good it wouldn't do it that long it
would have already been done you know what i mean wait has
it stopped already or is it still updating um it's done yeah
yeah oh it's done okay then can't be that if it has been
like if it has been going on for a while i don't think it
has i i really think there's just something that was it's
just your internet because like steam also does that for
they tend to take up the entire bandwidth i'm telling you
too like sometimes even in in like my room i'm getting
really bad connection and i'm like why am i getting bad
connection doesn't make any sense i'm like hardwired in
everybody's good um but yeah it's fine we have some great
screen caps like uh the one where i've seen a few of you
became caps where people you know where your model became
self-aware moving on her own yeah she starts slowly looking
at me and he's like what did you say fine it is what it is
like i said it's it's it's the journey not the destination
or it's the typical vtuber scuff i know you know the worst
part too with vtuber scuff is i feel like vtuber models are
getting more advanced yeah because of that it's like more
and more like remember when we had that collab for mint's
birthday yeah and like none of our layers work because
everybody just has these gigantic models now that's true so
oh it's just it takes up all the like space and we all have
to be animals i have a 50 90 and like games are or maybe i
have a 50 80 ti i don't but i have like a crazy graphics
card you know and even games now with my model will lag and
i'm like guys i have a tippity top of the top of the tip you
know yeah it shouldn't be lagging right anything like what's
going on there's so much more stuff that you always need
everything needs to be like optimized i was like oh sorry
you forgot to update your random driver in your random like
microphone chip and you're like damn it you're like what are
you talking about i just just take over aliens just take
over and and ready to plan for an event of a brown diet
childbirth at 23 come on yay I almost know what I have
where.
I have a 50-90 in LA and I have a 50- Damn.
I want to do a dual PC.
I've been trying to figure out a dual PC setup for the
longest time.
I will tell you, obviously you're good with tech and you're
a smart girl.
I am not.
But everybody that I've talked to that has a dual PC is like
my biggest regret is getting a dual PC.
Because they're like, think about anything that ever breaks.
Now you have to troubleshoot twice as much to see what broke
where.
I want to get dual PC because it'd be easier for streaming
like FPS games because I always yes That's like my my go-to
for the reason why I want to get dual PC because whenever I
stream like rivals or apex or overwatch I obviously my
frames get I did I played apex yesterday guys I played apex
The comeback guys actually I've been enjoying apex lately so
I'm actually come back soon change what um oh it was from
the tournament yesterday i had really a lot of fun uh just
shooting my gun so i was just like yeah sorry it's like hey
what do you like about shooting games i don't know i'm just
shooting my gun yeah just you know that thrill of it you
know when you go and then they die it's just so exciting my
gun i just want to shoot my gun but yeah no i i have i
always get tech issues okay so there was there was one time
when i was i was playing pragmata and then i there was this
one section in the game and we're at the ending we're
literally so close to the ending of the game and i couldn't
ride this tram to take me to the last stage like it kept
crashing for some reason it was always that tram part and
then dragon goons were like you got up to your drivers It's
the drivers, your drivers are, it's like, because I was
like, I haven't, your drivers are not up to date.
So then basically, last time I updated my drivers was
literally last year around July.
So, and then they're like, why aren't you supposed to update
your drivers, like frequently?
And I was like, no, like two, three months.
And I was like, no, you don't understand.
Every time I update my drivers, something goes wrong.
No, no, it's got worse.
Yeah, but apparently it's because, like, loaded apparently
by AI that's why it's getting worse I need you guys to
understand I've been the woman whose body I live inside has
been streaming for right yeah people are like how could you
be bad with computers back then it was so easy you put a
little Yeti mic the little ball you had a webcam mic you had
the shittiest webcam it just worked okay it was crunchy it
was grunkling now there's so much everything that it's like
oh this doesn't vibe with this and this doesn't but because
everything Yeah, nothing worked.
Yeah, exactly.
And then I updated the drivers.
We finally got to the ending and then like completed the
game.
But then right after my everything kept crashing, like after
I updated it.
And I was like, that's weird.
So after the update, I would, my basically, it was basically
my GPU was crashing.
So OBS was linked to GPU.
So my OBS was crashing.
I have to stream via my CPU now on my OBS.
um and uh i still i'm still doing cpu streaming just because
it's just for precaution like i don't know yeah just for fun
but it's because my cpu is really good anyway so i've been
using cpu streaming because i don't know there's nothing
nothing's going wrong with me using cpu streaming right now
so i'm like let's just keep going at it like but um but even
then when i first swapped to cpu streaming i was still
crashing but my obs wasn't crashing anymore it was just my
game was so and I realized I was like what's going on why is
my Jeep why is my why am I crashing all the time I realized
it's because of my drivers so I literally it took me like a
couple of days to finally figure out and and then it
literally I just downgraded back to my original driver and
everything's fine now everything like it's fine just like
that yep no crashes ever since what yeah it doesn't make any
sense yeah i'm using a year-old driver it's all right and
then the thing is i downgraded the driver to still a read
like still 2026 and i was still crashing i did like i
downgraded to a january driver still crashing so at that
point i was like well the safest one was the one in july so
i'm just gonna go yeah all the way back to july yeah i'm not
kidding it doesn't make sense i don't understand it it's
getting worse it's getting to the point where like it's
getting worse and every single time and and you know another
thing too with your models sometimes they update youtube
studio and like that becomes obsolete and oh yep one day y
'all i'm bringing back the webcam microphone and the and you
guys are just gonna have to deal the live reaction what was
it called the the the webcam uh c920 no no no not the you
know how like they do like the the bandy cap get that bandy
cap in there yeah hyper cap yeah the hyper cap get that shit
back bring it back yep i think i think it's gonna have to to
happen because at this point like it's getting so crazy and
then again like i live in a good then both streams so it's
like even though we're hardwired in suddenly like there's
problems with the internet or something happens or like ah
it's so much trouble yeah i agree i know i'm like grandma
yelling at clouds but no but i agree like just too much
issues with tech and everything and then there's even other
stuff where like now you know sometimes when i'm back in
like canada my my roommates live kind of like in a little
small place so oftentimes if there's like freezing rain yeah
the power And it's like, I get it that these houses were
built in like the 1920s, but also guys, like we cannot have
the power be shutting off because we have free train.
I have a job to do.
Or like during the day, they'll throttle the internet
because it's all just old people who like sit at home, watch
TV.
Yeah, because they're like, they're not going to use the
internet.
What?
Yeah.
They're like, please, there's not old people living here
too.
I'm sure I do my job.
I'm just trying to relax.
been tolerating a lot of this stuff lately and like i don't
know i don't know i just think there's a lot of vibe coding
too vibe coding is the way to go apparently now which is not
great vibe code you should do something where you're vibe
coding something with the dragoons no i'll just i'll pay
someone a vibe code for me i'm gonna outsource it yeah i
mean hey you're creating jobs exactly i'm a job creator i'm
here for i'm here for you guys no i i heard i heard a thing
that like a lot of companies have like uh like they actually
have a certain amount of tokens that they're supposed to use
per month and then you get in trouble if you don't use up
your tokens so people are like really trying to use up their
tokens yeah Yeah, it's generating me a picture of...
You're just randomly generating pictures.
Which is crazy.
That's crazy.
Is that where all the...
Is that where all the AI fruit videos come from?
It's just developers being bored?
What's the AI fruit?
Oh, you must have seen those videos where they do these
crazy stories with AI and they're like the use like fruit
people for it.
There's like love...
those videos i know but i can imagine it's the same thing as
like when you have like the little cat working at mcdonald's
or like the little cat driving the bike please ai fruit
people uh they're like ai i do see trouble if i don't use a
specific percent of our ai oh my sorry please continue all
right here let me show you a video of ai fruit they're like
it please i'm so excited their ai fruit stories it's crazy
i'm so ready for ai swap let's go tiktok let me see if i can
find it here i think this is one of them
i don't worry guys i won't link you guys the video you won't
be a plus one it'll be matara's plus one actually this is
this is exactly what i thought it would look like
so that's basically the ai fruit videos this is so funny
with anna what is this that's basically it there's so many
of like they so many generated gotta be like targeting to
kids like this is the new coke melon they're like i'm
looking around these have to just be targeted kids so i was
like is this real or ai
it's like oh my god my grandma my grandma had a strawberry
head and she is that a real banana are you happy to see me
i've got joki joki this was in the suggested links yeah
which one let's see my boyfriend is a werewolf there's a
part two and he's like he turned into like an emo guy after
with tattoos oh my god i like how he's crying all right
here's wounds is that jacob what is that oh my god wait he
licks the wound after he does this gotta be like catered to
kids oh my god it's like those like what is it called like
the hot content farms the the kid content farms well i'm
telling you now my whole feed is these videos and they have
so many for sure just as you said content farm sorry i'm
yeah it's a new it's a new content farm but instead of like
actual artists making it and now they're using ai wait
there's now videos of people that also look kind of ai
that's true that's true i've seen i've seen some of yeah
i've seen some of those videos too like now they just have
fruits on their head and like they're supposed to be the
oh it's like apparently like the number one of the number
one channels at the moment is one of the most not one number
one like the most profitable YouTube channel right now is an
AI channel but it's because they spam videos and shorts like
every other hour so it just builds up were you around with
like Reddit like am i the asshole okay yeah i have a deep i
have a deep cut for you um before i became a vtuber i fell
into the rabbit hole of these like a i guess it was like tts
it was like text to speech yeah videos read those yeah and i
remember like getting so close like i even recorded a few
and i just never published them because then auditions came
through for a certain thing and i applied instead but i was
very close because i was watching these videos man this
would sound so much better if like a real person read them
yeah but it's just a lot of them we didn't have sorry oh it
was just cheaper to use ai yeah well they did like tts and
stuff but i remember being like wait they're doing tts it's
kind of slop content also it's usually a male voice not a
female voice i'm like what if i just read and i did it i
ended up recording a few i didn't post them but i i yeah um
there there is an alternate timeline where i'm doing like
you should like post one video one day
Yeah, I was very, yeah, I was like, am I the asshole?
But with your models, with yourself on it too, and you're
just like, am I the little think it's you?
It's like, type in chat, if you think I'm the asshole.
Yeah, I just remember being like, because I wanted
experience in making YouTube videos and having a YouTube
channel.
And I was like, how can I get this experience?
It's by making video.
Surprise, everybody.
You get experience by doing the thing.
Mm-hmm.
So I was like, let me find something that I could suck at
and improve at and get better at like SEO, thumbnails, et
cetera, recording.
And yeah.
So there is an alternate reality where I'm like...
You should upload a video one day just to see how it goes.
Bring it back.
I'll see on my laptop.
But yeah, I basically like there is an alternate reality
where I'm just like reading Reddit threads out loud.
The M.I.
The asshole, girl.
You could have become her.
it's like you know how court's husband blew up like doing oh
yeah reading creepypastas basically it would have been me
but like am i the asshole there's a lot of those like i
remember that was like a trend at one point where it's just
people reading like reddit stuff off like uh just narrating
like stories and stuff because they just had they just had
the right voice yeah yeah i think that's always been a thing
because even there's a lot of podcasts where like what they
do is just read scary stories yeah read s or whatever like
it works there's an audience this is the craziest thing
nowadays is like there's an audience forever there really is
there i agree there there will always there will always be
an audience for something there will always be a niche for
something i'm not sober right now matara i'm sorry okay
we're putting in jobs but we don't get me in trouble you
know don't worry about it this was really really fun time
really yeah yeah i'm glad i was hoping it'll be a nice
distraction for you too because i know you have a lot of
work and stuff so like you don't yeah and you have to you
don't have to do any builds or anything use that brain that
one brain cell of ours that we share to figure out builds
i'm serious oh girl like i i feel the older i get and i
don't know if anybody else can i i just feel dumber like i
feel nowadays it just takes to like figures I don't know I'm
definitely getting dumber I know I am for real I think I
said dementia I think it's just because I stopped reading I
think that was my reason you know the hap okay the happiest
I had been lately I read back to back Brittany Spears's
biography and I was like I felt so much more connected to
the world it's hard to explain I maybe it is to read
something that isn't like emo you know just nice to not be
exposed to slop 24 7 on the internet you know okay do you
think we're slop i hope not do you think like a 15 apex
dream is like flop because sometimes i also worry about that
i'm like am i the problem no i'm not the problem i'm not i'm
not ai slop i hope i'm not ai generated i they're like it's
like generate this right now and i'm reading like i'm just
an ai reading off of my thoughts reading off of my
suggestion i remember seeing there's like youtubers that try
to do that like fully ai like youtubers oh my god what's his
name the quabble guy yeah yeah yeah yeah i know exactly oh
huh and then he teaches he has like several channels where
he's just ai he has an ai vtuber model and he has an AI, uh,
he has, like, he has an AI self and everything.
It's fucking crazy.
It's like the dad, like, he used to just play, what was it
called?
The Agario guy.
He used to be just the Agario guy.
And now he's the AI guy.
And everybody, everybody's trying to be the AI guy.
I get it.
Like, I don't, go ahead.
I just want to see how many fingers you can do.
It's weird.
Like, like, it's just like, and he's like, he doubled down
on it too, after people like we don't like this and you're
like well um you just don't understand you know the the
worst part about like doubling down is like yeah he's he's
real to you know values and his stuff and like like i'm the
kind of person unfortunately i have devil's advocate
personality where i'm like even if i disagree with respect
for like doubling down on your own shit like good for you
yeah i think you're dumb but good for you for like not
backing down you know yeah and it's crazy as like i'm just
like looking at his twitter account like he has like almost
like 350k followers on his twitter account but look at his
like um like engagement though so i'm it's like it's
probably like two likes or so because it's probably like old
followers that yeah yeah yeah and like you know you know how
there's a dislike button right now on twitter you dislike it
yeah so if you dislike something it would like go down like
it won't be pushed by the algorithm please don't dislike me
i i have nothing else going on for me please i beg you
please don't dislike our stuff please i'm gonna cry doki
this was i actually i never ended up ordering my food so i'm
gonna oh no
Oh, I mean, it was fun, though.
Just hanging out.
Time really flies by.
You got to get that food in you.
I do.
I really appreciate you taking the time.
And also, I know you don't stop in.
So thank you for drinking with me.
Yeah, of course.
I figured, you know, you would want to have someone to drink
with you too.
And it's like, it's a fun hangout.
I hope you feel a lot better, guys.
Send some love to Matara.
I'd love to be responsible for your alcoholism.
No.
Let's go.
if you see me if you see me go down that route just remember
it was matara's fault yep there you go you're gonna be like
poigra was my mom scratchers was my dad alcohol it was
matara khan yep yep yep yep all right i will then leave of
course of course go get your food i will once once you're
back and stuff and you're situated and you got everything
done um definitely let's actually do the game yeah yeah will
you for the pod once it's back up mm-hmm yes run it back
like not running back but let's like we never ran it let's
actually run deep rock galactic i never played deep rock
galactic says i i know you love that game too yeah start
running it okay start running it when i'm back yeah it's fun
it was good hangout i hope you feel a lot better matara i
hope that helped it helped thank you it really did honestly
just like getting my mind off awesome you rock jacuzzi homos
i saw you hanging out and being polite sorry my capture was
being weird but all right now she knows now she knows that
she can fix get it fixed yeah thank you um yeah thanks for
having me over i'm gonna go so you can say bye to them bye
of course everyone send some love to matara and say bye bye
bye please cry if you're gonna miss doki she's gonna be gone
for a week just cry if you're gonna miss doki cry cry yeah
and i'm definitely returning if any i'm definitely coming
back guys but in one week i don't stream matara kai was the
last person i talked to polymarket polymarket
Bye-bye, Matara.
Bye-bye.
Wow!
I am not so... I am not sober right now.
I had two cans.
Two cans is how it gets me, how it hits.
Wow!
How you guys had a fun time hanging out with Matara and I?
I'm glad we were still able to hang out together.
I was... What I suggested maybe instead of playing the game,
we could pivot to just a chatting stream.
Like, we both just drink and just relax.
chill and i'm glad it helped her out um and you know thank
you to everyone for saying some love over to matara uh two
whole cans you know how many percentages that is matara a
big whole five percent that means i drank 10 percent if you
think about it you think if you add five plus five it's 10
so now i'm 10 drunk um but um sorry we were a little bit
late i had to set up all the backgrounds and everything when
we did the pivot and stuff and i i accidentally bought an ai
background i thought i was wondering like why is it so cheap
because usually it's like a thousand plus yen and then there
was a back a background that was like 250 yen and it came
with like an animated everything and then i bought it
because it was a tiny thumbnail i was like that looks like
that doesn't look like ai and then i bought it and i was
ready to set every because i was like you know i was like
spending my time browsing through like backgrounds and stuff
trying to trying to figure out like trying to you know buy a
background to use for the stream and then i bought it and i
opened i was like oh that's ai i was like oh fuck no that's
definitely AI it so I have to go back and I have to find a
new background to use and set everything up again and this
one's not AI by the way this one's not AI um um yeah but
it's the saloon is not for okay saloon is for drinking but
like we want something comfy guys I wanted a comfy place for
us to uh that's why i took a while i had to set everything
up and i was also waiting for the food as well because i
thought uh the sushi was like like was my first meal of the
day um because like i said i woke up at 3 p.m because of the
fire alarm and um so i won't have food in my stomach before
we started drinking because i know it's not really good to
drink when you're when you're on an empty stomach and uh but
yeah also um uh today i found out that dad love also the
reason why dad hasn't been barking is that he's at the dog
sitter today that was also why i was like doing a million
things so i wasn't able to set set up stuff until at five
because i had to take dad to the dog sitter and also like uh
set up everything like get a new thumbnail made re pivot to
every like pivot to new stuff order food shower walk dad so
i was like just doing a million things answer one or two
work messages before i uh had to get started uh um had to
get started on stuff uh i really like that enormous tumblr
just like uh just like mint's huge coffee rice thank you for
the super chat Thank you, thank you.
So yeah, that's why it took me a while.
It took us a while to set everything up.
And then after a while, we were trying to get the collapse
to do it to work and wasn't working for some reason.
But I think it's just because of the internet issues and
stuff.
So that's why it took a while.
Anyway, today I found out that dad likes to eat washi tape.
night because I actually dropped washi tape on the floor
because I was trying to find something and I forgot about it
and then later that night I saw him chewing something I was
like what is that and I'm so sad it was my copy bra washi
tape and and then I was like and I found out he was like
chewing on it he was literally eating it and then I was like
no bad anyway obviously you can't salvage like fully chewed
up and like I think he just did because I was like this
looks a lot smaller than it should be and then today when I
was picking up this poop there was washi tape on
it was it was a washi tape on his poop so yep uh yeah um he
had some uh at least it came out that that's the good part
at least the washi tape uh managed to come out and didn't
fuck up his digestive system
he just he just really likes food and i guess it looked like
i don't know i don't know why he thought that was food i i
don't know um let's see what else did i want to talk about i
think that was that was everything i just want to tell you
guys about the little washi tape incident um but yeah i was
so tired last night like i said like it had the fire like we
were out there for three hours Like the people on the top
floors were allowed back inside And I had to finish my
autographs too And then after I finished it, I just passed
out I just went to sleep I was so fucking tired I was just
like Everything that happened Joki responded to work message
is still the craziest I think I'm gonna super chat Mercy,
thank you, thank you But I had a great time I still have
four more cans of Twisted iced tea.
of hard iced tea.
So, obviously, I'm not going to drink it all today,
obviously.
But at least I have some for the future.
I've never done another drinking stream.
I haven't drank in a long time.
oh, wait, no, the last time I drank was Project Hell Mary.
No, I just remembered about that.
My giant fucking fishbowl martini glass.
While I was just drinking Project Hell Mary to celebrate my
new bed before I found out my dog threw up on my bed.
it's cyber.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sorry, Doki, but what is washi tape?
It's just decorated tape.
It's like, people use it for stationary.
Like, there's cute designs and everything on it.
If you Google, it's W-A-S-H-I tape.
And you can buy, like, really cute tapes and you can use it
to decorate stuff and everything.
And it's easy.
It doesn't, like, it's easy to take off and it's easy to put
on.
Like, it's easy to rip as well.
So it's just decoration.
It's really, there's a lot of different cute styles and
everything on it.
If you're really into, like, decorating stuff, um, go check
out washi tape.
I love artists, so washi tape and everything.
And then they're really, really cute.
Um, but yeah, I think that's everything.
Thank you all for coming.
Glad we were still able to, I'm glad we were still able to
do the stream.
In the end, I figured, like, at first, uh, uh, like I said,
like, uh, she, I, I felt like I didn't want to force Matara
to stream because she was like, oh, I don't want to do my
POV or anything.
I just want to, like, chill.
And I just wanted to, like, there's a lot of work for it.
And I was like, that's all right.
We can reschedule.
I was so, I was totally fine with rescheduling everything of
what she was going through.
And I was like, if you want, and then I figured, like, oh,
how about if you want to, and I brought up, like, the idea
of, like, oh, you know, you want to get your mind off of
things.
We can still do something together if you want to.
And just, we just talk.
Instead, we just hang out and chat.
And I'll even drink with you, too.
So I'm glad that it helped a lot for her.
I'm glad that it helped distract her from everything that's
going on.
And that we were able to still hang out and everything.
I had a really nice chat with her.
It was really nice talking with her.
And I hope you dragons and mommos had a great time hanging
out with us today.
Oh, what's going on with Elle?
Yoki, can this dragon get congrats for getting a job and
being told I'm overqualified?
Thank you for the cool stream.
congratulations out for your new job congratulations i'm
super proud of you thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you hey guys i'm gonna call it here so i can sober up
thank you everybody for watching we had a great time hanging
out with us today as always everybody stay hydrated posture
check get up and move around to get that blood flowing and
if you said for me head to bed because you deserve it um any
final words i would say oh i should have asked matara if
there's any final Matara and I are both doing our own
concerts in LA.
So please feel free to check out her concert and my concert.
This is Matara's very first venue concert as well.
If you want to support her and anything, she's also doing a
concert like two days before my concert, so check it out.
Here.
Here it is.
And also there's my concert too.
Hey guys, I'll see you all later everybody.
Bye bye guys.
Bye bye.
See you in the next video.